[Música]
en Primera Plana
Carlos Serrano
[Música]
Bienvenidos en primera plano un programa
de radiofrance internacional y France 24
en el que hoy intentamos responder a la
pregunta que todo el mundo se hace
tenemos que tener miedo a la
Inteligencia artificial está carrera que
cada vez vemos más en los medios de
comunicación o en las agendas de los
políticos para intentar responder a esta
pregunta nos acompañan en este estudio
tres invitados ya les presentol
coordinador de Inteligencia artificial
en la escuela de ingeniería central
superior aquí en París bienvenido
es periodista en nexting pad
especializada en nuevas tecnologías
bienvenida gracias Carmen Y tenemos
podemos también con el periodista y
realizador Tomás bienvenido un gusto
estar aquí Tenemos que tener miedo a la
Inteligencia artificial nuestra pregunta
hoy en Primera Plana
[Música]
un grupo de expertos investigadores y
empresarios han firmado una carta
abierta en la que piden una tregua en
los desarrollos de Inteligencia
artificial durante seis meses alertan
sobre una carrera sin control y sobre
profundo riesgos para la sociedad y para
la humanidad en su conjunto hablan de
poder destructivo de la tecnología y de
peligros sin precedentes hoy nos
preguntamos en Primera Plana si están
fundados o no estos miedos y Qué
herramientas tienen los estados para
legislar sobre la Inteligencia
artificial que parece que avanza a una
velocidad que era impensable hasta hace
pocos meses repasemos algunas portadas
que nos deja la prensa juega
internacional la Inteligencia artificial
en pista libre haciendo referencia a su
avance exponencial en nuestro mundo Hay
diarios aquí en Francia como Liberación
que han dedicado números especiales este
asunto dice el rodativo que es todo un
Enigma para la evolución del empleo de
economics en Reino Unido Apuesta por el
bridget Cómo hacer de Reino Unido una
superpotencia en Inteligencia artificial
luego hablaremos también de la
geoestrategia en todo este asunto bueno
es la pregunta que todo el mundo se está
haciendo y me gustaría que todos aquí la
pudiéramos responder el poder
destructivo al menos en potencia de la
Inteligencia artificial es una amenaza o
no para la humanidad jule Obviamente que
sí pero para pero sí es una es una
amenaza no te va a matar hoy en día no
te va a matar pero es una herramienta
muy importante en términos por ejemplo y
son cosas que son muy poderosas ya hemos
visto peligros con los
con Facebook Twitter y ya tenemos eso
pero sobre este oro hilos es decir no no
una amenaza en el sentido destructivo
para la vida humana pero sí en el
terreno ya de lo que vemos de que
circulen todavía las fake news todavía a
más velocidad de lo que de lo que ya
pasaba con redes sociales Matilde Cómo
responderíamos si puede ser alguna
amenaza para para el discurso público
para la sociedad civil como como
discutimos juntos y cosas así pero no me
gusta tanto el tema de la del miedo
porque puede impedir a pensar las
soluciones que podríamos crear para para
poner límites sobre estas tecnologías y
estas tecnologías son humanos que lo
creen que lo construyen que lo
desarrollan y por eso creo que detrás
del miedo hay que ver que tenemos
responsabilidad como sociedad para poner
límites donde se puede ser y para quizás
prohibir
unos usos
precavidos más que alarmistas les veo de
momento toma
te acuerdas la película Terminator Sí
bueno desde hace algunos meses estoy
esperando que llegue a cherseyneger para
decirnos que tenemos que quebrar la
máquina porque nos va a matar Así que sí
para mí es una amenaza global y
que viene en más de otra otro cambio que
hemos
vivido sin verlo que es casi un cambio
de civilización
todo el internet las redes social
cambiaron nuestra manera de conectarnos
con nosotros de informarnos de
aculturarnos y con una herramienta tan
poderosa como la Inteligencia artificial
sin ninguna especie de control estoy
realmente aterrorizado cualitativo
tecnológico de una envergadura muy
importante Bueno aunque los medios y la
agenda política no dejemos de tratar
este tema me me gustaría que brevemente
pongamos un poco en la definición en
cuestión habría que hablar de
Inteligencia artificial en singular o en
plural en plural hay varias
inteligencias artificiales hay una
pareja
hay varias tecnologías para hacer cosas
distintas Y si hablamos del programa
obviamente
es que hablamos de Inteligencia
artificial para Designar el campo de
investigación y sus aplicaciones y esos
son lugares sociales muy diferente
porque en campo de investigación se
investiga todo el todos los días pero
las aplicaciones ya están en nuestra
vida cotidiana Como por ejemplo no sé
aplicaciones de reconocimiento facial o
o modelos algorítmicos que ayudan en las
finanzas a calcular inversiones o cosas
así hay que hacer una diferencia entre
las funciones
que que entender que todo este tema de
la inteligencia artificial no es siempre
tan artificial es decir hay una gran
investigación del diario
que nos explicó que para dar los
resultados inmediatos de una
Inteligencia artificial eran cientos de
trabajadores pobres que estaban haciendo
como un trabajo muy muy debativo de clic
clic para lograr a hacer pasar este
trabajo para el trabajo de una máquina
pero eran verdaderos hombres seres
humanos detrás de esto así que también
hay siempre con la tecnología una parte
de comunicación de marketing y hay que
tener no miedo pero tener en cuenta que
también están vendiendo algo y que
cuando te quieren vender algo no siempre
te dicen todo lo que hay que saber en
este producto claro lo complicado en
este asunto es saber dónde poner el
cursor exactamente entre la prudencia y
el alarmismo no donde porque es
complicado con todas las noticias que
nos encontramos día a día en prensa no
sabemos exactamente
miedos Sí pero hasta qué punto a lo
mejor estamos siendo muy alarmistas los
medios a lo mejor no cuando un grupo de
investigadores piden una tregua y lo
hemos visto estos días en el desarrollo
incontrolado de la tecnología de seis
meses les pregunto para qué estos mis
seis meses de tregua para que llegue el
para que legislemos para qué
Hay que entender Quién firmó este eso
porque sí obviamente hay buscadores pero
también hay un mes que tiene sus
empresas de Inteligencia artificial y
que tiene interés a lo que eso se calma
para estar a la página
claros
entre tecnológicas obviamente y además
no puedo entender eso porque en un mundo
cerrado si puede ser Interesante pero
estamos en un mundo global y quién cree
que China o Rusia van a acabar sus
investigaciones
Estados Unidos o la Francia también el
problema si si vamos a hacer estos seis
meses de pausa es que hubiera gente
seguro que si quiere
hacer sus investigaciones en secreto y
para las sociedades es mejor haber
investigación abierta de Cómo podemos
hablar juntos y así eso pero si es un
discurso marketing para gente
eso en cuanto a la lucha entre
tecnológicas Pero en cuanto a lo público
estamos en una carrera sin control en la
que gobiernos estamentos públicos se han
quedado atrás y tienen dificultades para
seguir por lo menos en lo que se refiere
a legislación cómo se adecuan esos
tiempos el tecnológico y el de la
legislación porque parece que el
desacople es el gran meollo de la
cuestión pero el tema es que la
tecnología no es un producto como los
otros productos de Gran consumo Es decir
que si quieres por ejemplo
construir un coche y ponerlo en la venta
tienes que despertar ciertos cierta
regulación ciertas especialidades
ciertas cosas en la tecnología la
mayoría de los productos que utilizamos
son en beta es decir que no son
terminados Y
todavía están funcionando es decir que
estamos aceptando de utilizar productos
y no sabemos si estos productos
funcionan bien o van a hacer un tipo de
problema Este era la realidad de
internet y de los redes sociales tenemos
la misma problema con la Inteligencia
artificial claro lo que pasa es que
tengo la sensación que los tiempos se
acortan es decir es verdad que teníamos
reservados los problemas que existían ya
y ahora viene otra otra parte de
problema que va más rápida más poderosa
más potente y de la cual hay que decirlo
no entendemos nada la mejor respuesta es
siempre la adaptativa ante un salto
tecnológico porque es difícil ponerle
puertas al campo Por así decirlo pero
les pregunto cómo debe ser esa respuesta
por parte de los estados y las
organizaciones internacionales si
ustedes tuvieran asesorando a una
organización internacional a un estado
que les aconsejarían
en términos de tecnología
internacional
en la gente que toma decisiones y cosas
así pero si tenemos
feminismo del feminismo y las nuevas
tecnologías Sí claro
debemos
debemos preguntar a transparencia de
esos
empresas sobre esas tecnologías tenemos
que poner límites Como por ejemplo hay
casos de uso que no queremos como
sociedad y casos de uso que son
aceptados para quizás hay que hay que
poner responsabilidad sobre el sobre la
gente que construye a estas máquinas y
ahora no está el caso siempre digan que
como si hay problema es más o menos la
culpa del usuario y eso no no eso qué no
soy muy inocente por preguntarles esto
pero una armonización internacional es
del todo punto utópico
Sí para mí es utópico porque no podemos
entendernos sobre nada hoy en día en el
mundo pero yo no tengo miedo de la
organización porque para vender las
empresas tendrán que ser confiable y ser
abiertas porque si no los estados por
ejemplo no van a comprar y eso va a
cambiar también con el cambio de
mentalidad del pueblo
ley no está no es una ley pero hay
instituciones como la ONU y el UNESCO
quien
que ha escrito unas recomendaciones
sobre la ia y hay muchísimos países que
firmaron este documento no es bueno no
es bueno la Unión Europea ya va por ha
intentado dar muchos pasos ya en este
asunto
Los italianos están dando un ejemplo de
lo que se puede hacer en Italia hay un
juicio un proceso en proceso
porque cuando una Inteligencia
artificial trabaja va a utilizar todo lo
que existe en internet para darte el
resultado No si le haces una pregunta va
a utilizar la cosa sobre la moda por
ejemplo
invéntame una una falda bueno va a tomar
todo la falda que existan y crear algo
no y en Italia hacen un proceso porque
la utilización de todos estos datos
que pueden ser datos privados datos
personales
no pagan por eso y si no pagan por la
utilización de una parte del producto
Hay un problema así que eso va a ser
también una parte de la gran cuestión
sobre la Inteligencia artificial es como
estos
computadores pueden utilizar o no el
material que existe en internet y afuera
de internet para dar la respuesta en
este punto voy a hacer una breve pausa
pero vamos a volver enseguida para
seguir tratando todos estos miedos de la
Inteligencia artificial a quien en
Primera Plana hasta ahora
en France 24.com siga nuestra
transmisión en vivo
encuentre toda la información que
necesita
noticias en directo las 24 horas del día
y en cuatro idiomas
infórmese sobre los temas que le
interesan
Busca la actualidad o la repetición de
una emisión conéctese
a un clic la información internacional
en directo
libertad
reporteros el programa de reportajes de
France 24 descubra las historias de la
gente con nuestros reporteros por todo
el planeta
nuestros periodistas van donde ocurre la
noticia para contársela cada semana
reporteros le trae una historia inédita
no se la pierda
reporteros en France 24 y 24 punto com
Seguimos aquí en Primera Plana de radio
Francia internacional y de France 24
esta semana intentando resolver la
pregunta que nos hacemos en todos los
medios todos los políticos en todas las
cafeterías del mundo la Inteligencia
artificial puede acabar con la humanidad
esto es un alarmismo o es prudente
planteárselo estamos intentando poner
elementos encima de la mesa para
intentar calibrar el sentido de esta
duda nos acompaña
el coordinador de Inteligencia
artificial y los periodistas toma su son
y Matilde salud les pregunto la
Inteligencia artificial no es mala en sí
misma o la tecnología podemos decir en
general que no es mal en sí misma lo que
es malo es en las manos en las que caiga
porque de hecho quien la vaya a usar
para hacer el mal seguramente ya estará
encargándose de disponer de ella sí pues
es no es mala en sí misma pero es un
nuevo herramienta para la mala persona
Sí y por ejemplo podemos ver a los pan
por ejemplo Todos hemos recibidos están
súper mal escritos que no tienen sentido
y que no Fernando con la Inteligencia
artificial puedes hacer spam muy sibrado
y muy bien hecho que tú y yo vamos a
crear es decir si mejoran las
herramientas que el mal puede utilizar
Sí también
muy muy eficaz para escribir a
ciberataques y como código para atacar
sistemas informáticas pero si hay casos
de uso de nuevo de la tecnología que son
malos o peligrosos A menos estoy segura
de esto por ejemplo sabemos que con un
tipo de reconocimiento facial no
funciona de la misma manera con la gente
bronca y negra o las mujeres y los
hombres y si las ponemos este tipo de
tecnología sobre
los vídeos que la policía usa por
ejemplo esto es esta es hecho en los
Estados Unidos hay verdaderos problemas
para las libertades civiles porque hay
[Música]
unos hombres que ahora bueno no ahora
pero que fueron en prisión en carceleros
por la culpa más o menos de modelos
algorítmicos erróneos y esto es un
problema grande pero claro a corto plazo
lo que estamos viendo y tomar tratado
muchísimo el tema de las fake news es
que precisamente la desinformación y la
propaganda gran escala y la posible
eliminación de trabajos de todo tipo de
tergiversación de la información y de
cómo circule a nivel exponencial aún
mayor es el riesgo ya a corto plazo
luego hablaremos de otros que pueden
afectar a la vida humana pero a corto
plazo es este no dos ejemplos muy recién
el primero es durante las protestación
durante la reforma de las pensiones
tenemos el jueves y el viernes dos fotos
la primera foto que salió era un futuro
de un hombre viejo sangrado
que supuestamente había golpeado por la
policía nos costó como ocho diez horas
en los checkers a verificar esta imagen
a darnos cuenta que no era verdad que
era seguramente fabricada por una
Inteligencia artificial y decir bueno
esta imagen no está válida Así que es
una fake news el día siguiente salió una
foto de una mujer viejita también
sanreada también golpeada por la policía
y
antes de decirnos Bueno se puede ser
inteligencia no no está no está
verdadera pero esta foto era una
verdadera foto tomada por un profesional
un fotógrafo en una protesta y
la posibilidad de hacer el falso no
impide la verdad Pero pone en duda
siempre todo lo que se dice y es un
cambio dramático para la democracia otra
cosa y es más la la rapidez la necesidad
de en la cual se puede fabricar y
difundir una imagen me tocó en un
momento estoy en instagram veo el hijo
del
expresidente Trump Eric Trump pone una
foto de Trump caminando en la calle de
Nueva York con muchísima gente Detrás de
él la pueden Instagram y en el momento
en el cual estoy viendo esto hay ya 600
miles de personas que pusieron un like
en la foto así que ya fue difundida de
manera global y me hago un poco el
ejercicio no me pongo en Twitter bueno
vi esta foto cómo vamos a hacer una
clase de fatching Vamos a darnos cuenta
de cuánto tiempo para verificar esta
cosa Qué tipo de detalles podemos ver
otra red social Bueno me tocó como 10 15
20 minutos en mirar en detalles y todo y
al final les digo bueno el falso fue
hecho por un tipo el tipo además me
viene en Twitter diciéndome
la cosa muy importante en esto y es que
esta cosa era falsa totalmente creada no
tiene ninguna raíz de verdad y fue
difundida a casi un millón de personas
antes de que pudiéramos decir si era
verdadera o no En qué mundo esto se
puede aceptar ya no nos acordamos de los
tiempos en los que veíamos las cosas y
no nos teníamos que preguntar sino
ciertas o no ahora ya vivimos tiempos en
los que no te creas lo que ven tus ojos
hay que verificar verificar la voz
verdad Bueno lo veíamos en las portadas
y por ejemplo aquí en Francia con los
últimos movimientos de macron
entrevistándose con elon musk la carrera
que ya han lanzado algunos países antes
hablamos de empresas de tecnológicas
pero también países por ser
superpotencias en este campo hay alumnos
aventajados ya en esta carrera
geoestratégica yul Matilde toma Me
parece que los países que han puesto
una inversión en la tecnología siguen en
este camino es decir que los chinos
están trabajando muy duro en el tema los
gringos también están los
norteamericanos Lo siento
están haciendo estadounidenses Sí y me
parece de que en Europa estamos más en
el término de La regulación que de la
búsqueda
pero la diferencia
es que la la búsqueda en Europa es más
científica y Universitaria que
empresarial Y eso cambia mucho la la el
lugar en el cual se va a hacer la cosa
no bastante de acuerdo contigo sí
hay mucha búsqueda universidad eso es
cierto pero también hay mucha búsqueda
empresarial pero como no tenemos el
tamaño crítico y el crítico estamos
comprados por Estados Unidos a un tiempo
matil por mucho que lo llevamos
Inteligencia artificial lo que produce
la tecnología resulta que lo hemos
creado también los propios humanos con
nuestros propios sesgos usted que es
crédito tanto sobre feminismo y nuevas
tecnologías cómo se evita que la
Inteligencia artificial reproduzca los
mismos estereotipos también le pregunto
a la pregunta con una cara B
Si no los llega a reproducir esto
Quisiera decir que ha superado también
el estereotipo humano no sé si es
todavía más inquietante
hay distintas respuestas posibles la
primera es corregir a los datos que
demos a los modelos para entrenarlos
pero
si los datos tienen prejuicios también
es porque son imágenes de la sociedad
que tiene prejuicios y este señor
El señor tiene un cerebro y está con sus
prejuicios absorbiendo datos No sí pero
el problema es hasta los prejuicios más
fuerte que son en la sociedad otro otra
cosa es que la industria está no está
muy diversa en la industria de
tecnología en el país en los países
occidental
Hay muchísimo más hombres que mujeres
por ejemplo y no es que todos los
hombres quieren a a poner
sobre las mujeres pero como no hay
diversidad no pueden saber en unas
partes como hacer mejor y como y como sí
producir a mejores tecnologías y otra
cosa es las razones económicas y
políticas porque construimos
una máquina o una ia porque esto va
probablemente a crear unos tipos de
prejuicios también por ejemplo Sí sí por
ejemplo sobre la redes sociales Si
quieren que nosotros sigamos pues con la
información sobre esos redes sociales
van a construir máquinas que nos van a
mostrarnos información muy violenta y
cosas así porque saben que eso nos
nos hace
Sí
Nuestras relaciones con el empleo
entendemos que los trabajos más
mecánicos son los que a lo mejor
pudieran desaparecer pero también hay
colectivos que están muy preocupados
creo que actores de doblaje ya se ha
movilizado también en algunos países
como como México y las agendas políticas
cada vez vemos Ya el tema de la
Inteligencia artificial en todos los
sitios no sé si también nos vamos a
encontrar posicionamientos ideológicos
en los programas políticos respecto a la
Inteligencia artificial es decir que
dentro de poco en unas elecciones
vayamos a votar con criterios sobre este
asunto o Qué les parece toma a mí me
gustaría mucho poner poder estar en
capacidad de elegir a un candidato que
tiene algo que decir en el términos de
tecnología en la última elección
presidencial había en el inicio como 40
candidatos
en Francia y y no había ni un solo que
tenía algo que decir sobre la tecnología
Así que el problema en sí no había ni
una pero no está candidato a la
presidencial como candidato
presidenciales y no hay nadie que tiene
algo ni siquiera
Interesante pero a lo menos algo quiere
decir en este en este para mí para mí
este este
lo más importante Hoy día hay temas que
acaban arrastrando a los políticos es
decir por mucho que no quieran hablar de
Ecología al final la realidad es tozuda
y se implanta El problema es que sea
demasiado tarde y este tema va a ser
parecido por mucho que no quieras
afrontarlo ahí lo tienes y vas a tener
que hablar del tema este tema no es tan
lejos del término ecológico porque la
máximas de de más datos de utilización
de más computadores esto tiene un costo
ecológico muy grande cada vez que manda
un email no hace Bueno
[Música]
sí sí sí es muy importante y lo vemos
construimos siempre más por la
tecnología y tenemos una esperanza que
tecnología nos apoya a reducir nuestro
impacto Y quizá va a llegar un día pero
algo por el momento estamos subiendo Por
cierto el gran peligro Entonces es que
este sistema se esté comportando de
forma inadecuada y la persona no lo
detecte digamos que la supervisión en
todo esto es la clave y les pregunto Y
quién debe controlarlo quién supervisa
al que supervisa es decir qué poderes
van a supervisar este tema porque no sé
si está ahí la clave rápido matil que me
queda muy poquito tiempo bueno el
parlamento europeo por ejemplo está
trabajando sobre esas preguntas pero hay
supervisiones clave en esto supervisión
del gobierno de empresas de auditorios
Si eso puede ser de todas partes de la
sociedad civil también si si ve que hay
un algoritmo muy duro algoritmo
algorítmico que no funciona bien puede
necesitamos que que habla de eso
verificable
podrían checar
pues ha sido muy interesante me quedo
sin tiempo para más Muchísimas gracias
julto más y Matilde no sé si hemos dado
razones yo creo sí hemos puesto sobre
todo encima de la mesa razones para
calibrar los miedos de este tema que
cada vez tenemos más y tratamos más en
los medios de comunicación que es la
Inteligencia artificial vamos a volver a
hablar seguramente del muy pronto
Muchísimas gracias hasta la próxima
semana en Primera Plana gracias
[Música]